so she wouldn't got this lovely big
spatula and this is yours is smaller
than mine
to say it's real funny how picky you're
deciding to be right now with a mug
looking but what I'm just saying it's
really interesting hi I'm jasmine and
I'm destiny how's it going I'm Alex I'm
Hannah today we're gonna try to make mug
cakes with no recipe so I thought we
were making mud cakes I didn't know what
a mug cake was coming into this I
thought it was some kind of British tea
oh I'm not really a mug cake kind of
person I want the whole entree I don't
want an appetizer I think I've even
eaten them I think the difficult part of
this is making it be like a cake can
rise I might have a really cool
chocolate soup at the end of this I
think I mean the hardest part is the
recipe I know like eggs milk and flour
go into cake do you really put a whole
egg in here hole in it you're thinking
really scared I'm really scared there's
so many things in front of me let's say
our goal today is to not have it explode
in the microwave that's always my goal
in cooking with my go ahead are you
ready no me so I'm gonna start by
melting some of this butter we're gonna
have to because there's no oil here you
either do a canola oil or butter in a
Kate I sound like a dork but four
tablespoons of butter in there I was
doing you don't even know the
measurements I know we're not gonna use
four tablespoons of butter I'm gonna
microwave four tablespoons of butter and
I'm gonna give you half let's get that
going in the meantime
oh wait that's great
we probably could have use the other one
too this looks like enough for one you
mean to tell me what mix-ins are you
feeling for your cake I'm thinking
chocolate chips you're sure that's a
great choice do you want to make this a
chocolate cake I think so
just to stick with my dream of it still
being a mud
Oh sugar I think you're gonna want to
put that on top of your wet ingredients
don't go okay if you just take more than
white butter a lot of butter we're gonna
want to do some milk 1 tablespoon to two
[Music]
hey I'm confident that I know just by
looking
how much tablespoons is yeah I was gonna
fold how much flour did you put in 1/2
of a teaspoon that doesn't feel like
make your own mug cake I'd let make my
own okay I'm gonna go half a tablespoon
1 2 baking soda to make it rise right I
think so
whoa it says that serves about 12 to 15
biscuits
I'm just gonna do a little yeah oh wait
you use the fourth teaspoon I use like
half and go fourth
okay that's not too bad the biggest
thing you need to make sure is that it's
overpower the flavor yes smaller brushes
smaller brushes oh we should add a pinch
of salt are we done with the flour a
pinch oh how much did you put in there
just don't overdo it
so it was like pretty good
I hate that's annoying yeah this does
not look anything like that
what does look like soup the more I stir
this the more confident I feel I feel
like that is super thick this is like
cake I've taken up half my batter into
the whisk
do you need more Mitch looking one more
like a mud cake you need to add more
powder because it's soupy I think about
like when you make a cake what we rather
like maybe flour honestly I don't know
what I'm doing so if you listen to me
you did it at your own risk
that's two it's a little sad it's a
little empty but it will taste good
yours looks way better than mine it
looks like a cake I'm afraid I'm afraid
to cool mm-hmm not a fan how do I know
if it's rising add some more milk to
that because that thing's really trying
for something it's very dry I think I
might have overdone it on the cocoa
powder how long do we microwave this
pizza rolls or what no no no I'm judging
by Lean Cuisine mm-hmm you can see where
we are at it in life let's just give it
a minute 30 and see what happens
oh god no no oh maybe some nutmeg you
think that'll do it
no really you asked I have too much
money that's your lunch no told a lot of
it too
it smells like Christmas why is it so
hunky
you said add more flour added more flour
no no try it oh that is not Meggie
it is this just looks like I've made
frosting maybe I can frost your cake
with like a oh y'all I think mine's an
actual cake
go in there baby go and grow my baby is
growing flourish Queen I'm very proud of
this
it looks like cake it does I don't care
what it tastes like it didn't explode
you got to get the bubbles out I'm
already smelling something interesting
whoa I was one of those people taught to
always clean up behind yourself cooking
what good thing you tapped out those
bubbles look how much mine rose wow you
know what the crazy thing is I make a
bomb or some chocolate cake I with a
recipe find that hard to believe how you
feeling champ I got a little bit off
that fork and it's gross okay well
things might change do you want whipped
cream tea oh yeah boys alive fill the
empty space with whipped cream so it
looks like I have a nice tall yeah this
smells like girl don't even say it
hey Jax cleaned sighs oh I have an idea
we're just gonna go with the chaos I
called this tropical storm chocolate
until storm
[Laughter]
thank you such finesse now I need my
little men my troopers for the storm
thank you there's a story bears to
demolish it's literally melting as I
speak I don't have much
[Music]
mine is not bad but tastes like why is
it good oh wow is it yeah this is okay
it is a really hard on do sprinkles you
wanna switch it's not bad it tastes like
bread your smells so good though doesn't
it
there's nothing there good here's pretty
good too
it does taste like bread I actually like
yours more I like my more - oh you're
cute
[Music]
it's not anything wrong with it you just
put too much nutmeg I will never do this
again
I think this would be fun for like a
sleepover mm-hmm the M&M or clutch on
yours to add the sweetness yeah I think
the more just already made things that
you could eat added to the cake helps
when the cake doesn't have much going on
we can switch back no you don't have to
eat anymore fine
yes that's easy I really make a bomb-ass
lava cake I just don't need to do
anything without a recipe you got the
lava
[Laughter]
[Music]